first time i heard about it no jordan
called me so yeah i'm doing a film
oh yeah what's it about
[Music]
this film's about many things but in its
core this movie is about a brother and
sister oj and emerald as the only black
owned horse trainers in hollywood since
the moment pitchers could move
we had skin in the game
oj is the one that stayed he runs the
ranch he's just in a place where
everything is unraveling and his sister
comes back into his life and he's
remembering like oh man you're not yeah
you're not doing anything you're not
helping are you chilling tonight at work
emerald haywood doesn't really have a
lot going on doesn't really know
everything she's talking about but she's
got charisma
and she really doesn't know where she's
going
we have the great daniel kaluya my
all-time favorite actor he's somebody
that forced me to push to unlock further
things in the character and kiki palmer
she has this spark she just crushes so
the relationship as close as it really
is you might not really be able to tell
until [ __ ] really hits the fan
[Music]
it's about their ability to go from not
connecting to acknowledging they have
always seen each other they just innate
love for each other a brother sister
being friends they're certainly being
real i have rarely seen that let's go
boy
i'm trying to save you my brother is out
there
should i do it
thumbs up
[Music]
you